[vent qui souffle]
Salut à vous peuple des Internets !
Et bienvenue dans ce décor un petit peu remodelé pour décembre !
Et pourquoi ?!
Ben, écoutez je vais vous le dire pourquoi, c'est très très simple. [imitation Sarkozy]
Puisqu'au 1er au 24 décembre, j'ai décidé cette année de vous faire un calendrier de l'avent.
C'est-à-dire que je ne suis pas le chocolat,
mais cette chaîne sera un calendrier de l'avent, tous les jours du 1er au 24 décembre, il y aura une vidéo qui sortira à 6H00 du matin, sur la chaîne.
Pourquoi 6H ?
Parce que je me disais que ce serait pas mal.
En fait, peut-être avant d'aller en cours,
mais comme c'est à 6H, tu n'es pas obligé de mettre ton réveil à 5H59, par exemple.
Ce n'est pas grave si tu la regarde à midi.
Tu vois le principe.
L'idée c'est que sur ces 24 vidéos, je vais vous faire des vidéos un petit peu normales,
un petit peu style Mental Vlog,
vous savez, mais il y aura la petite particularité qu'à chaque fois je vous présenterai quelque chose que j'ai.
A moi, ou que je vais acheter spécialement pour la vidéo,
qui sera une idée de cadeau de Noel potentielle, pour vous ou pour quelqu'un...
Alors attention, on est bien d'accord, idée de cadeau pour les gens qui aiment les trucs un petit peu dans mon délire !
Parce que si c'est par exemple pour qu'un qui est fan de mécanique automobile, je ne suis pas sûr de le passionner avec des choses qui me passionne moi.
Cette introduction est beaucoup trop longue !
Je le précise aujourd'hui, j'essaierai de ne pas le rpéciser à chaque fois mais il s'agit pas de placement de produit,
c'est quand même important de le dire.
Tous les objets dont je vais vous parler seront tonjours dans la description,
ainsi que d'autres idées de cadeaux.
Ca peut être une place pour venir me rejoindre à l'Olympia le 22 septembre 2018 !
En voilà une idée de cadeau très bonne pour faire ce spectacle ensemble.
De toute manière vous avez toujours un lien vers mon livre, mon jeu, etc...
Mais ce n'est pas le propos, on n'est pas là pour faire de l'autopromo,
Sinon la chaîne s'applerait Fabien Olicard.
...
Comme c'est la vidéo n°1, c'était vraiment aussi pour vous expliquer le concept, mais je vais quand même vous faire voir un bouquin,
c'est un EscapeBook.
Alors c'est quoi ? C'est la rencontre entre les livres dont vous êtes le héros,
et les escape room, ou les escape game.
C'est-à-dire ces salles où vous devez sortir en 60 minutes chrono, et il y a une maison d'édition, 404  éditions,
ils ont décidé de faire ça version papier.
Et ça marche très très bien. Ca c'est le nouveau qui est sorti et qui s'appelle "Le Piège de Moriarty".
Et en clair, vous allez résoudre une enquête pour Sherlock Holmes,
vous êtes un agent en fait de Scotland Yard.
Et vous allez devoir résoudre cette enquête.
Donc il y a une vraie histoire, au départ, et après il y a des indices, des énigmes à résoudre,
des labyrinthes à l'intérieur même du livre.
C'est vraiment très très fun. Je ne sais pas si vous avez connu "Le livre dont vous êtes le héros",
d'ailleurs vous en voyez apparaître quelques uns autour de moi,
bravo Loic !
Ah ! Tu as mis celui-ci je l'adorai !
Ca me permet de vous dire, que ce n'est pas moi qui vais monter toutes ces vidéos, et qu'à chaque fois je ferai ça, il y a quelqu'un qui ferait:
"Ah !!! Mais il faut vraiment que je rajoute une image là ?!"
Eh bien oui, tout à fait.
Bref, c'est bien au-delà d'une énigme simple,
tu vis une vraie histoire quand tu fais ça et dans cette histoire la tu as des rebondissements etc...
Il y a une difficulté qui est... en fait c'est une difficulté qui est dans certains jeux vidéos,
ça me le fais aussi, c'est-à-dire que ce n'est pas trop simple, mais tu avanceras toujours, tu ne seras jamais réellement bloqué.
Si vous voulez vraiment un livre d'énigmes pour vous prendre la tête à mort, sans trouver de solution,
j'en ai pleins d'autres à vous conseiller,
ça c'est vraiment fun, et tu avances quoi qu'il arrive, c'est juste que tu participes vraiment et c'est assez interactif.
Je trouve ça cool. De cette édition la, de chez 404,
j'avais fait le premier, c'est pour ça que j'ai acheté le deuxième.
C'est "Prisonnier des morts", c'était vraiment dans l'univers des zombies,
donc rien à voir, on est plus dans un truc du style "Walking Dead".
Là c'est vraiment dans l'univers Sherlock Holmes,
on est en 1890, ou 1891 dans le bouquin. J'ai à peine commencer, donc
je ne peux pas vous en dire plus, et je ne veux pas vous spoiler même si je l'avais déjà fini.
Voilà ! C'était mon idée cadeau de Noel !
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? Qu'est ce que vous en pensez de cette idée aussi là de faire une vidéo par jour pendant 24 jours en mode calendrier de l'avent ?
Dites le moi dans les commentaires, parce que si jamais ça ne vous plaît pas,
sachez qu'elles sont tournées,
et qu'elles sortiront tous les jours à 6H du matin.
C'est comme ça ! [rires]
Dans les commentaires vous pouvez aussi donner d'autres idées connex qui vous font penser à ce livre par exemple.
Des idées de livres ou de jeux dans le genre que vous aimez.
Et puis si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'oubliez pas de la liker avant de partir.
De vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait,
ça se passe juste là !
Ici ! Dans ce cercle la !
Et moi je vous donne rendez-vous demain, où nous ferons la deuxième ouverture de ce calendrier de l'avent.
à 6H du matin ! Wesh c'est tôt ! Et c'est ça qui est cool !
A très bientôt !
Ciao !
[musique]